[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
junk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please be seated
peace be with you it is with the first
words that the resurrected Jesus spoke
to his disciples that the cattle it
literally usually begins when it is
pretty president back over by a bishop
peace be with you it seems to me that
these words are appropriate as we come
together in this Cathedral to remember
the battle of Chania which in 1918 was
decisive in leading to victory I'm happy
to welcome you to this Cathedral a sign
of hope in the Sun from almost 8:00 and
yes I particularly wanted to pay tribute
to the representatives of our allies who
some coming from the other side of the
world were essential in putting an end
to the great world soldiers from Great
Britain on Ireland Australia Canada New
Zealand South Africa and the United
States of America came to fight
alongside the French army they
sacrificed the life to allow us to come
out of this disastrous conflict it's
important well we are all world to all
of them together I also pay tribute to
the representatives of Germany who have
joined us it's together that we wish to
build the future for we are not only
gathered together in this Cathedral to
remember
our presence here remembering the
senselessness that penetrated the first
world world is also a resolute
commitment to peace we know that it can
only be built within justice and truth
the sense of remembrance is always turns
towards the future which calls on our
responsibility
I wish you an excellent commemoration la
Paix SWAT avec vous c'est parti Komodo
geodesy city as a discipline Kokomo's a
visual malady Georgia College can tell
proceed upon Eric la Paix SWAT avec vous
en la sombra Cosimo's dantavakra a la
coruna said catedral from souvenir the
lobotomy on key or disturb Saudis with
tight a deceiver of you de la victoire
visible devadasi Cathedral Synod
Esperanza on Saturday Sunday Pidgeotto
reasons own subhadra's al vento
particular mo lira kazuto-dono Zhou Yi
given above certain diluted moon
essencial permit Rafa a leg hunger the
Soldado grande rata need around the
solid you can add a de nouvelles alone
the fig decided is it as you need
America so renewed about hakuta do love
me Francis it won't fail the sacrifice
de la vie
tonu permit destructive ii flee disaster
yet Oporto nutrition ensemble lesson or
a salut Oh Celia present Oh
Dalal Monica new sovereign citizens own
canoe sweatin Bhatia not a venir car new
no son para some lead off a cathedral
Salma porno souvenir not rock reasons I
see resume more dole absurd Kia
traversal apamea geminal hoc Onaga
smalheiser
tulip a new low servo selfie no para
conseguir que da nervousness la ville ET
la sol de la mémoire a - shoo - never
leave me geobella not responsibility
Giroux sweat in Belgium MOOC
I am delighted to join you all today to
mark this important centenary in this
historic Cathedral of a mural from the
very first start of the First World War
a miaar found itself at the heart of the
conflict for most of the war it was just
behind the allied front lines and
military personnel soon became a
familiar sight on its streets around its
shops cafes and hotels for thousands of
servicemen it became a home away from
home above all a meal was a city of
connections its railway line was a vital
link between Paris and the north here
the armies of France and the British
Empire came together it connected the
Allies during the defense of the city
against the great German offensive in
April 1980 shelling and bombing
destroyed many of the buildings here
thankfully this great Cathedral was
spared significant damage in the summer
of 1918 this was the springboard for the
Alice's offensive which would eventually
lead to victory on the western front
after French American and British forces
had turned the tide against the Germans
in the Second Battle of the Marne the
scene was set for a truly coordinated
allied effort to strike back what began
here on the 8th of August was truly a
coalition operation under the strategic
command of a great Frenchman Marshall
fought a battle in which the forces of
many nations came together to fight in
which aerial mechanical and human
courage and ingenuity combines with
devastating results a me on was symbolic
of the auntaunt Correale the cooperation
without which victory was impossible it
is entirely fitting therefore that today
that same international coalition has
returned for a meal with our former
enemy in peace and partnership it is
fitting to that we come together here in
this magnificent Cathedral which is such
a refined connection to all those that
served after the war a commemorative
tablet was installed here by the
Imperial War Graves Commission in sacred
memory of six hundred thousand men of
the armies of Great Britain and Ireland
who fell in France and Belgium during
the Great War
Memorial tablets were subsequently
installed by other nations to honor
their fallen and the chapel of the
Allies where today we will renew the
bonds forged during the war is a lasting
testament to the continuing relationship
between those who served here a hundred
years ago and the people of ammon today
we return to learn more about the
experience of those involved during the
historic summer of 1918 to honor the
fallen of all nations to commemorate all
those who participated in this great
endeavor and to celebrate the bonds of
friendship which unites our nations
yes Dena gallito Kanta Antonio de la
cosa de creville atmospheric eelinator
Mia lago de paseo de um Elysian aunt
olive on todo el rancho said max
business engagement Lezama Devon traumas
longitude earlier General Electric
avodah Comaneci a no sólo cuerpo
received alarming unless le refugee dr.
Jean trinomial lamentable traversal
eh-eh-o eh-o mode Amin WA Y desecrate
apart rule and even senado de una zona
dong was the material military a
diversion Dalbir da schon éamon de oz
johanna soir chemin de fer swap our
canoes automobile Keala a to today's
yolk Montone Co holy Co desolate on
Damien
yes a literal malecon sevilla de Porres
Porto near death of Connelly le bon toda
la noche para que podamos an evacuation
want a park to Sara panicky vomit and
venomous the new morality circulars on
the prisoners element
hey Sadako hezmana of us live under the
redness on the street contrary hot hello
I'm Jung Joo civilian counsel who
repeated [ __ ] lemongrass result in a
girl
open it home no ha sido ahmadiya
immediate malukas ransom only disaster
currently little electric the tramway
elephant degras ship on de la mota blue
mahogany room
uh no blue as a curve in querido to
telco bahasa for see directly the
classroom class this young people is
explosion who about you they need are
some labelled from the drought were a
typical t22 who demands chakra chakra
here the in due to a midwife Andre who
has I dunno boom - you would
in brief from Wolfgang cancer and then I
turn on each Vista and hit now ghosts no
it's no not art sale soon so I are to
give Alyssa here
demons evil arrogance and so on which we
defended a matte town in France versus
London bonded over kilometer right in
the day s which telling neutral Mojave
won't make out Madonna yet snot many
after Carter the island Vega ferfolia TB
Indies influye you buddy like in further
the songs left circulate AB C's Ollie no
Alomar in on some fatal and the dog
Givens I'm done recently is fillet trick
to got super wartime over senator lugar
más nueva and a month observation wheel
stained in Agnes Monash down'n on owner
here in Beijing Games will be first to
win big liver only thank you my name
shop for the society fuel aha didn't
mood undefined protons filled with kite
have kit host Christ so game first off
no means in lost loot of fun hoon cans
on its wake jihad and where mister so
stay in via in Australia informal data
when defined Blin ridden
division of the visual indefinite
entitled as well sick Alice
some best man for her to finish with
9,000 health gurus or I live there
Wolfgang
[Music]
[Music]
a massage demon a selfish kominato
served as our main ally homie paracrine
and a sticker or general de Beaune don
imagine a dinner suit Rubino todo que la
première army forces do a Tatar agua
Oprah to Istanbul Amma a lot version
Connor resultado ha optional
Lassiter SEO sal de casa que yo ha
affair sir et voila
okö davao suppressants mo park honorable
600 Audrey Kim no faucet our dear
Oakland possibility Don so beaut
oucampus in the for Hawaii the division
authority on our hair cell kinabalu
services so DubLi passed on do ZM Linea
yup shoes Jessica's go scot ocke Tony
Rowe resulta voulu
palooka non mashup area don't believe it
merciful Minerva Pardo a PA pada Eric
two more
Cheska opto co-director set what
condition
really it only backed don't kill guru
General John J Pershing declaration to
Prime Minister Clement so Marshall Faulk
and Marshall Papa at Marshall Fox
headquarters in Claremont on 28 March
1918 I've come to tell you that the
American people would consider it a
great honor for our troops to be engaged
in the present battle I ask you for this
in their name in my own at this moment
there are no other questions but up
fighting infantry artillery aviation all
that we have are yours use them as you
wish more will come and numbers equal to
requirements I've come especially to
tell you that the American people would
be proud to take part in the greatest
battle of history General Sir John
Monash was message to his troops the day
before the start of the Battle of omean
for the first time in the history of our
Corps all five Australian divisions or
tomorrow engaged in the largest and most
important battle operation ever
undertaken by our Corps because of the
completeness of our plans and
dispositions of the magnitude of the
operations of a number of troops
employed and of the depth to which we
intend to overrun the enemy's positions
this battle will be one of the most
memorable of the whole war the work to
be done tomorrow will perhaps make heavy
demands upon the endurance and the
staying powers of many of you
but I am confident that inspired of
excitement fatigue and physical strain
every man will carry on to the utmost of
his powers until his goal is one for
Australia the Empire and our cause
Lieutenant General Sir Arthur curries
special order to the Canadian Corps in
March 1917 which was restated during the
1918 German spring offensives under the
orders of your devoted officers in the
coming battle you will advance or fall
where you stand facing the enemy to
those who fall I say you will not die
but step into immortality your mother's
will not lament your fate but will be
proud to have borne such sons your name
will be revered for ever and ever
by your grateful country and God will
take you unto himself
extract from Field Marshal Haig's dari
the 7th of August 1918 at 2:45 p.m. I
left for flexy Corps where I had a talk
with general rowlandson everything is
going on without a hitch and the enemy
seems in ignorance of the impending blow
I then went on to headquarters Canadian
Corps at Dury
and saw general Currie commanding the
Corps the latter said it had been a
hustle to be ready in time
but everything had been got in except
two long-range guns the platforms were
ready for them and they would be got in
by tonight last night was our most
critical moment if the Germans had
bombarded the Canadian zone
we could not have retaliated last night
tonight the situation is quite different
and we are ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a next red blue red rocket rocket ozm
criminal Fanti new model for
three-year-old another appreciate the
design company Latakia vetoed opt jewel
soda conscious ruin from the Catalan
kill Ahmed Musa vol is only a new truck
or satirical Canadian consider
chronology of the Baja Michelle Devon to
nestle in some partial attack deputies
appointed in Mateos almond on position
Gavin not rocket ffs the new semi Tanuja
was a raffle the new crochet young
people it
Gunilla to double on usability attache
lock on Tony DeFries eme try Arabic
marcharon results are a.cian Demetrius
come mmm Mateo Zulu Fisichella Osito
Laval Ababa MSU's no de la Torre de
Landa president of ERDA the VL Okinawan
sushi with amiable Holloway Demetrius
not even to literal apprentice
appreciation kolmogorova
with the pasta in battle across arterial
model is a real monkey pond only
punitive arteries at the middle is a
very few Prison a the grenade specialist
a doll a girl they can operate a toy
Aquino Prisco Sevilla orchid concat
Academy you could not show enforces
oculi the propagation of a trade on the
moon design the kilometer
panel travels resonate with avenue de
cadaver de Sol de France a cavity trail
of the levonne's almond on marks a key
TST
Charlotte ever alone plasma will set on
babe Cumberland Arizona the tag do we
taught me enough shanties with Liam and
OTO Melara small refugee a media
resection machine you the number
blessing
this account is from Major General a a
Montgomery the British commander of the
Fourth Army 13th Corps describing the
American forces at a Mian at the 9th of
August attack on Druze air woods the
American swept everything before them
and the German resistance collapsed so
precipitate was the retreat of the enemy
that a German battalion commander fled
from his dugout abandoning his orders
map and telephone switchboard the
Americans were so impetuous that they
outstripped the British on the left and
it was due to them that the objective
was so quickly and rapidly gained on the
front of the 58th division
from private Southie of the Australian
core the morning of 8 August started
very foggy indeed
and as our barrage opened a tremendous
barrage we were wondering how we were
going to get on but forward we pushed
and met comparatively slight opposition
some Germans surrendered quickly others
fought to the end as we pushed on
wondering where we were the Sun broke
through we began to see the countryside
that we hadn't seen for quite some time
it was unscarred all sorts of cultivated
land we began to feel
by Jove the war's coming to an end we're
getting through and we had a feeling of
great uplift about the whole job
extradition oligarchical NL table
commands vendors iam bataillon star
expeditionary energy la Madonna a
tarantula
Lynn - impose a duty in attack terrible
at imminent the million aluminum or the
concentrate on Oh Camille in here Engr
Fawad habla Natak additional product
launch control in me bum ba da ma fi
habla nothing
cackle vain Matane lotta paid it lad
awakened violence in we a Sukkah
Valdiserri Duda see fed to suit a solid
Russia and me that infantry advanced
supportive Ally tank news Mo Kio
collagenous material the considerable
they can all demetria's certain reason
is account per million attack Frances I
will see the organization often sellable
nickel easily on the pyramids Malaga
lend me attended my battles of dream in
a conference and success final remoting
no / solar cotton
from tank commander Wilfred Bion
describing what he experienced on the
8th of August 1918 at 9:50 p.m. handley
page bombers would you to start flying
along the front the noise of their
engines were supposed to cloak the roar
of the tank engines so the enemy would
not become suspicious
soon we heard the characteristic
pulsating tone just then from 2 miles
away
we heard the roar of the first tank
engine starting up the tanks after the
first one helped to screen each other as
each engine started
the driver throttled down to slow speed
so that the raw became a diffuse murmur
and the murmur became an
undifferentiated sound like traffic on
the roads it was just possible to
believe that the enemy would be deceived
the following is an extract from the
post-war memoirs of polish on Hindenburg
German army chief of staff on the Battle
of amia August 8 1918 on the morning of
August 8th our comparative peace was
abruptly interrupted in the southwest
the noise of the battle could clearly be
heard the first reports which came from
Army Headquarters in the neighborhood of
Tehran was serious the enemy employing
large squadrons of Tanks had broken into
our lines on both side of the AMIA sank
on Town Road further details could not
be given the veil of uncertainty was
lifted during the next few hours though
our telephone lines had been broken in
many places there was no doubt that the
enemy had penetrated deeply into our
positions and that batteries had been
lost on this August 8th we had to act as
we had so often acted in equally
menacing situations initial successes of
the enemy were no new experience for us
we had seen them in 1916 and in 1917 at
via Daraa Arras Vitz later and calmly we
had only quite recently experienced and
mastered another one
it's Warsaw but in the present case the
situation was particularly serious the
great tank attacker the enemy had
penetrated to a surprising depth the
tanks which were faster than hitherto
had surprised division of stuff in the
headquarters and torn up the telephone
lines which communicated with the
Battlefront
I had no illusions about the political
effects of our defeat on August 8th
our battles from July 15th to August 4th
could be regarded both abroad in at home
as the consequence of an unsuccessful
but bold stroke such as may happen in
any war on the other hand the failure of
August 8th was revealed to all eyes as
the consequences of an open weakness to
fail in an attack was a very different
matter from being vanquished on the
defense the amount of booty which our
enemy could publish to the world spoke a
clear language both the public at home
in our allies could only listen in great
anxiety all the more urgent was it that
we should keep our presence of mind and
face the situation without illusions but
also without exaggerated pessimism
[Music]
they were young as we are young they
served giving freely of themselves to
them we pledged amid the winds of time
to carry their torch and never forget we
will remember them
[Music]
is that a giant condom is also a V then
the national was madame roola chromatin
and amidst octopus the patella prabhu
indonesia memory do new soviet holder
[Music]
it is foolish and wrong to mourn the men
who died rather we should thank God such
men lived
[Music]
they are not dead not even murdered only
their dust has gone back home to the
earth for they the essential they shall
have rebirth whenever a word of them is
spoken
sous-sous demands male betray lo quiero
cerca de fool en le o le preborn o Lord
o el Creepo to to grow our fado pass it
on if a man a confirm a la voix de pub
aunty livers or alcohol
[Music]
they shall not grow old as we that are
left grow old age shall not weary them
nor the years condemn
but they're going down of the Sun and in
the morning we will remember them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
an extract from the Great War as I saw
it by Canon Frederick George Scott
senior chaplain first Canadian division
here and there I met wounded men walking
back and many German prisoners in the
fields in different directions
I could see rifles stuck bayonet
downwards on the ground which showed
that there lay wounded men I found that
these were chiefly Germans and all of
them had received hideous wounds and
were clamoring for water poor men I was
sorry for them for I knew be long before
they could be carried out or receive
medical attention
owing to the rapidity of our advance I
made my way to each intern and give him
a drink from some of the water bottles
which I carried round my belt I think
all the Germans I saw that morning were
dying having been wounded in the stomach
after attending as far as it was
possible to their bodily needs i
endeavoured to mist her to their space
spiritual as they happen to be Roman
Catholics I took off the crucifix which
I wore around my neck and gave it to
them they would put up their trembling
hands and clasp it lovingly and kiss it
while I began the Lord's Prayer in
German this happened many times that day
one man who had a hideous wound in the
abdomen was most grateful when he handed
to BMAC the crucifix he took my hand and
kissed it it was strange to think that
an hour before had we met we should have
been deadly enemies
now film Tom Fong gathered in Italy ich
bin xodar don't escape fate advice for
niemand innovate dome connect easily in
tarnished fiim the Comets are the first
and playa
Tamia dine builds or NAFTA tinge laughs
as you would me in Dinah Nate who
expense all that understand faith
theorem almond for Nevada which two
houses Lhasa two old ship would vote
Alana enzyme lab sofa vincas it'sand
Methos Incan Josh Lawson and August
diner thinkin expense all dartium to
even failed here ended Allah mentioned
wait the arrogance Inc the nation'
strain and fleas connect stone nor Bly
fascism biasness varoom
whose dog hearts of isthmus in scroll
that heart and shoes
a quarter of left-hand Harold Williams
of the fifth Division Australian
Imperial force who was wounded in the
Battle of Perrin and evacuated to a
casualty clearing center at Dell that
these women were there long hours
amongst such surroundings with that
collapsing spoke volumes for their
willpower and sense of duty the place
wreaked with the others of blood
antiseptic dressings and unwashed bodies
the nurses saw the war stripped of even
the excitement of an attack they saw
soldiers in their most pitiful State
wounded blood-stained
dirty reeking of blood and feels the
strain was such that it was almost
incredible that a woman could stand it
and retain her sanity
a letter from Frank cousins Canadian
soldier to his mother mother on 12th
November 1918 my dear mother the
remarkable and long looked for day as it
last arrived and the happenings of the
past week are beyond my power of
description how much has happened since
on the morning of August 8th we were
awakened out of our doze in that motor
lorry
as the big guns belched forth the first
rounds of the barrage for the AMIA
affairs how little we thought that in
less than four months the victory would
be won it is hard to realize that is all
over and for me over here the truth will
not be fully appreciated until we reach
home but war is no more in our time at
least and we can once more move and live
and have our being in short be human
the words of Major General George Bell
33rd division commander United States
Army two leftenant general RHK Butler of
the British Army 11 August 1918 the
division is proud to have participated
in this historic battle with the gallant
British troops under your command permit
me to send you the most hearty
congratulations on the brilliant work of
your forces and to express the confident
hope of further combined victories for
our combined arms
external Ermenegildo shows wa Maradona
de Mendoza says am innocent is nerve
vetoed la zona de todo esto hasta la da
astre , told Evelyn bataki Doha trauma
deliver on de Burgh amia Voyager des
amis almond anudo no osa la victoire la
communique desert Gaddafi opportunism nu
a vagabond lyubov 8o s Reva no truth Oh
troll vape on donation a oppressive are
conceded nesco news attic on acid de
Medici a free aboard on sagal travel
alarm osceola zona communique c'est la
victoire
seller delivers dhaumya ova poverty
Integra new no Siham prude a refugee
Puma predation or not Khmer song I
taught in Abba table in food had over an
over [ __ ] family Allah
doot-doot no fishy do service for este
es una turkette Vallejo converging evil
commandant hijo de Parfum sido para ello
sub k FF in a keinosuke pro-democracy Oh
Donna Juhani la guajira Varnado few
Villa de la catedral de Coelho prefer a
low command on da Gama
a fixico yellow fellow a not imam ahmad
a shellfish
la vela bein twist Mallory Oh deja vu
switcheroo viz mode oppression a domino
monument bombard a enemies and Emily's
Rizzoli amia a vida
lemagas ah so so much Indies alleges in
symmetry is so mature come here
sociable Aveda mo la population operate
a player Virginie amia cap in
organization complete a permanent Durov
item Oh Damien material despotism
an extract from the war memoirs of Prime
Minister David Lloyd George 1918 the
fact of the matter was that the British
Army itself did not realize the extent
and effect of the triumph they had won
that day they were thinking in the terms
of past offensives when a gain of a few
kilometers in an attack was as much as
they could hope to accomplish and
experience had taught them the dangers
of advancing too far because the Germans
invariably rallied brought up their
reserves and counter attacked with verve
and skill they had not yet understood
that they were confronted today with an
enemy who had lost much of his - and
combative strengths the reports of the
battle received by the Cabinet from the
front showed how little even the victors
understood the immense effect of the
triumph they had won the actual ground
captured was not extensive the effect of
the victory was moral and not
territorial it revealed to friend and
foe alike the breakdown of the German
power of resistance more finally even
than by the French counter-offensive of
July the 18th were the Germans driven by
the British stroke of August the 8th to
realize that all hope of victory had
passed after the July defeat whilst they
came to the conclusion that their
offensive had finally failed they still
hoped to reorganize their army
effectively for an impenetrable defense
after the army our battle even this
seemed impossible Ludendorff admits
the 8th of August demonstrated the
collapse of our fighting strength and in
the light of our recruiting situation it
took from me any hope of discovering
some strategic measure which would
re-establish the position in our favor
an end must be put to the war
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for me
[Music]
[Music]